this is the part where we're going to
smash the a PST which is a pivotal point
in the Battle of Endor
there's the one-on-one spite of all the
logs mash rig was tough to build I first
was going to actually use strings and
then I was like we're never going to
glein up like it's going to clip one
side so it's all EB C coated in magic
sculpt and then I sculpted the log
texture over the PVC and then added a
lead pipe in there just to give it like
more punch and this thing's super
fragile that means you kiss it's right
in the middle model right great easy
we're gonna do a test on this orange can
see how much we can crush it three two
one go
this YB tasking yep three two one go oh
it really looks like the strings are
doing it oh look at the hip two one go
and dig that okay as our height everyone
ready Gophers are going so it's gonna go
three two one go ready here we go three
two one go oh yes I can't wait to see
that
just like in the movie it's like a movie
oh it's just that's 100 times better at
those well that one caught up I want to
see people get out oh there you go